Good afternoon.
Thank you for staying late in the meeting and for coming
to our forum on multi-cancer early detection,
titled "Where We Are and How We Realize the Hope."
I assume I have to press on here.
So I'll just take a minute
to introduce
the two speakers that we have.
Peter
Sasieni is going to talk first. His title is "Multi-Cancer
Early Detection: Where Are We and Where Do We Want to Go, to
Get To?" He's a professor of cancer
epidemiology,
co-leader for the Center of Cancer Screening, Prevention, and Early Detection
at Queen Mary University of London.
And then
Ruth Azioni is going to follow with the title, "Navigating from Hype to
Hope in Multi-Cancer Early Detection." She's a professor by statistics
program, Public Health Science Division, and it's a
Rosalind and Harold Ray Brown chair at Fred Hutch.
And then I will follow with my perspective on
multi-cancer early detection. I didn't put my picture.
I thought that would be weird
to do.
So you can see me. I'm Nick Papadopoulus from Hopkins, by the way.
So we called it a forum when we were organizing this with ACR, with the idea
that we're not going to present new data per
se and revelations. It's more like presenting
data to kind of establish our ideas about multi-cancer early
detection. As you've noticed also from the titles that
we have different expertise, and all of us are trying to
work towards
developing those tests and testing those, and evaluating those tests.
So we expect to have potentially different opinions about things,
and we would love to hear your opinion and have a healthy discussion.
So we're going to give short talks, one after the other,
and then we're going to take questions from you, or we'll discuss
things in between us about multi-cancer early detection.
So save your questions till the end.
That gives you the opportunity to hear perhaps different takes on the same
subject. So, Peter, I think you're first, so please
come to .
Thank you. And just to say that that QR code, I don't know if we can go
back to it.
Oh, thanks. Yeah.
That QR code, if you can ask a question during any of the talks
using that QR code, and then we'll get them all at the end.
So, thank you.
Yeah. Thank you very
much.
These are my conflicts.
Some of this talk will be factual. If I get something wrong,
I apologize, please correct me. Some of it will be my
ideas to progress the science. You may disagree profoundly.
Quoting Salman Rushdie, "It's ideas that should be protected, the
discussion of ideas that should be given a safe space." I'd
like to thank AACR for creating that safe space, Nick
for giving me a platform, and Ruth for arguing with me
and challenging my ideas.
In January last year, a review of clinical effectiveness
identified 13 cohorts in 17 case control studies.
A second systematic review, published in November, identified 20 studies
with 19 different tests. With so many tests, the results, not
surprisingly, were all over the place.
There's an ongoing systematic review by Julia
Steinberg from Australia that's about to submit, I believe.
That's focusing on interventional studies.
We published a non-systematic review in August last year
discussing the promises and pitfalls of the current MCED test,
highlighting the challenges in translating a test that may be good at
detecting cancer in asymptomatic individuals into an
effective screening program that reduces cancer morbidity and/or
mortality in the population.
The first of those papers provided performance statistics on five
commercial tests, all reported specificities of at least
96.4%.
But note,
with a specificity of 96.4%,
nine times as many people will have a false positive test compared
to a specificity of 99.6%.
So whereas they're all very good, some are better than others.
With one exception, the sensitivities range between 20% and 70%,
but as I pointed out in a recent editorial, traditional test performance
metrics are not useful for multi-cancer screening tests,
and the estimated sensitivity will depend heavily on the mix of cancers
included.
Where reported, sensitivity was lower for detecting earlier
stage than later stage cancers. One company claims
90% sensitivity, but there's precious little
peer-reviewed data about its test.
So of the five tests, one is based on methylation of cell-free DNA,
another a combination of proteins and gene mutations in
cell-free DNA, and now they're looking at
methylation. A third sequences
cell-free DNA and then combines methylation, fragment length,
fragment end motifs, and copy number variation.
One uses multiplex fluorescence immunocytochemistry
to evaluate tissue-specific markers on circulating tumor cells,
and the fifth uses electrical properties of the blood
sample.One issue
peculiar to multi-cancer tests is the identification of the
tissue of origin. Some tests rely on whole body scanning in
patients with a positive screening test.
Others provide a supplementary result that indicates where the cancer
may be found and directs diagnostic workup.
For many tests, the performance of the tissue of origin identification
in those with a true positive is excellent.
In February, Grail announced that the NHS Galleri,
the only randomized controlled trial of a multi-cancer screening test with a
clinical endpoint, failed to achieve its primary endpoint, a
statistically significant reduction in stage three and four cancers three
years after the last participant was enrolled.
While the result is disappointing for the field, the announcement also
reported a favorable trend in reducing stage
four diagnoses in high mortality cancers.
There's also a suggestion that a reduction in
stage four cancers increased with longer follow-up, as would be
expected from natural history modeling.
They also reported increased detection of stage one and two cancers and
a substantial reduction in cancers
presenting through emergency presentation.
Although not the primary focus of the trial, these results point to
clinical benefits of annual screening.
Full results will be presented at ASCO at the end of May.
In October last year, results from the first 25,000
participants in PATHFINDER 2 were presented.
The positive predicted value of a positive Galleri test was 62%,
substantially higher than with any existing screening program or
indeed most symptoms. Only 67%
of people referred with urgent suspected cancer in England
are diagnosed with cancer.
And with 12 months follow-up, the episode sensitivity of
the 12 types of cancer that are the focus of the test and which cause
two-thirds of cancer deaths in the US was 74%.
Tests based on cell-free DNA may never be able to detect
most stage one cancers and certainly not intraepithelial
neoplasia and adenomas.
My lack of optimism is because such tumors don't seem
to shed DNA.
Modeling suggests that the limit of detection of Galleri is at roughly
0.1% tumor fraction. Below this threshold,
the test has very little sensitivity, whereas above it, the sensitivity
is extremely high.
In other words, improving the algorithms using
AI is unlikely to make much of a difference.
This also has positive implications in terms of overdiagnosis of
solid tumors. Because the level of DNA shedding is a
proxy of tumor aggressiveness, the chance of significant
overdiagnosis from the use of such tests, multi-cancer tests,
is very small.
Protein markers have a role in improving sensitivity
to early cancers.
Whereas cell-free DNA comes from dying tumor cells, proteins
may be produced in response to a tumor.
For this reason, protein-based biomarkers may permit
detection of very early cancers, albeit at the expense of reduced
specificity.
Similarly, even small tumors produce a substantial amount of cell-free
microRNA secreted via exosomes and microvesicles.
Since much microRNA is protein bound, it is more
stable in the blood, and with a longer half-life means that it is
more easy to detect.
Thus, microRNA based tests are likely to be more
sensitive to early stage tumors, but because they can be
influenced by inflammation, they will also lack specificity.
Several MCED tests are available commercially, but none has yet received
FDA approval.
The FDA granted breakthrough device designation to Guardant Health's
Shield multi-cancer detection test in June 2025.
Grail submitted a pre-market approval application for Galleri
earlier this year.
The NCI's Vanguard study
was launched in July last year. It aims to recruit
24,000 participants aged 45 to 75 over
two years.
It's a feasibility pilot designed to test the logistics,
processes, recruitment strategies, and diagnostic workup
pathways.
It will test 8,000 people twice a year apart with Shield,
8,000 with Avante, and 8,000 participants will be
controls.
The study is due to complete in 2029.
The intention is to use the results to design a study of
225,000 people, randomized controlled
with a cancer mortality outcome.
That trial will not complete before 2038.
By that time, technologies will have moved on.
By contrast, industry has been generating data at pace.
At ASCO, Grail will present three-year follow-up on data
of the 140,000 participant randomized controlled trial of
MCED screening versus usual care.
And in answer to a question on Monday,
Tom, Exact Sciences said that they are planning to do a randomized
controlled trial. I don't know when.
PATHFINDER reported on the psychosocial impact of multi-cancer screening.
Anxiety scores were increased at the time of disclosure of positive
results,
but returned to baseline within 12 months.
No changes were observed in those with a negative test
result.The
clinical need is for a screening test that can find potentially fatal cancers
while still treatable with a curative intent.
The harms of periodic screening should be small compared to the benefits.
Ideally, the test should work for rare cancers too, because it
is only through multi-cancer tests that we can ever consider
screening for rare cancers, which combined account for about a
quarter of all cancer deaths in the US.
We must consider not only the frequency of harms, but also their
magnitude.
If a false positive test results in a CT scan or a
colonoscopy, it does little harm.
If it requires surgical removal of a nodule, that is much more
concerning.
Further, to prevent a diagnostic odyssey or exposure to relatively
high levels of radiation, a positive screening test should be
accompanied by a result that helps to locate the cancer.
If we think of screening as a series of sieves, tests based on
cell-free DNA may be regarded as a very coarse sieve.
They only pick up big cancers, but almost everything they do
find is likely to be cancer.
We also need a very fine sieve, a biomarker like
amino acids or microRNAs, that can identify people with
early and even pre-cancer, but which may also select a
lot of people who don't have cancer.
Consider a screening test with 90% sensitivity to cancers
that might become symptomatic over the next three years and
70% for those that might become symptomatic between three and
10 years later.
Even if the specificity was only 80%, a
biennial screening with such a test might be extremely useful.
We might screen every six months with a very specific test,
those who identified at high risk, and annually those at moderate
risk.
If the sensitivity but not specific test also
identified site of origin, one might triage with a
single-site screening test such as colonoscopy or low-dose
chest CT.
In preparing this talk, I asked Google AI what Ruth would say
about the future
of MCED screening.
It said,
"Etzioni would likely advocate for a go slow approach
that rigorously validates these tests in trials, focusing
on minimizing patient harm and
ensuring the technological advances
benefit the community rather than thus being driven by
commercial hype."
I would agree with much of that.
Scary.
But I strongly disagree with the emphasis on go slow.
To the contrary, we must search for a faster approach that still
ensures rigorous evaluation. The focus should be on maximizing
public benefit rather than minimizing patient harm, since, in my
opinion, used carefully, these technologies have been shown to have
minimal harms. Indeed, it is the potential harms that are being
hyped in the scientific journals.
We need to go faster because there are 2.6
million cancer deaths in Europe and North America each
year.
The results of the main Vanguard study will not be available for at least
12 years after NHS Galleri.
Suppose MCED screening could cut cancer mortality in a population
by 8%.
Had the results been strongly positive, the go slow approach
would have cost 2.5 million premature deaths.
If the trial results are negative, having conducted it
faster does not change the harms.
If the trial is falsely positive and we start evaluating
screening at scale, what is the worst that might happen before we
realize our mistake?
We could waste a few billion dollars on screening,
but losses of that magnitude are common on the stock market.
Maybe 100,000 people would have had a positive test before we
realize our error.
They would have had transient anxiety because of that test result.
Most will have had imaging or endoscopy to rule out cancer,
but very few will have been seriously harmed.
Many will have had cancer diagnosed earlier than it would have been, but
overdiagnosis is unlikely.
Based on what we know about these tests, about the harms of Galleri,
we can quantify that the harms are not great.
Suppose screening works, but its rollout is delayed by 12 years.
What will happen on the impact on society?
Those with the best healthcare will get
screening of the new test privately.
But those who are health deprived, those who are most likely to be
diagnosed with a late-stage cancer, will not benefit.
Health inequalities will widen, and society will become more
divided.
I would screen a million people a year in the US as part of a
pragmatic trial to generate more evidence.
I would focus on people aged 60 to 74 with the greatest risk
of being diagnosed with a stage four cancer.
I would offer screening to those attending for targeted lung screening,
attending a stop smoking clinic, a weight management clinic, or a type 2
diabetes clinic. I would invite people living in the most
deprived neighborhoods,
and I would only start screening in people whose
age was divisible by five, so as to create a natural
experiment that would generate rigorous results on the impact of MCED
screening on cancer
mortality.We
have a multi-cancer screening test that finds cancers in about one in
200 people screened. That is one in 200 people
for whom there was no cause for concern.
Of those who test positive, over half have cancer
diagnosed.
In NHS gallery, there was a substantial reduction in cancers diagnosed through
emergency room presentation.
Technologies improve year on year.
Now is the time to work out the logistics for a wide-scale
implementation of MCED screening, with an emphasis on
reducing health inequalities and providing practical guidelines on
diagnostic pathways. Whatever you think of the clinical
utility of the current MCED test, it is hard to deny
that the future tests will deliver a paradigm change in the way we control
cancer. Thank you.
Well, Peter already gave my talk, so.
I want to thank Nick and the AACR for giving me this
opportunity to talk about a revolutionary, fascinating
topic that has occupied much of my waking
life for the last several years.
I'm really excited to be here, and I'm really excited to hear from all of you.
Let's
get started. I have no disclosures. Okay.
Why are we susceptible to hype about MCEDs?
Probably many reasons. Here are just three.
There is an ingrained belief that early detection is always good.
This is an old, probably more than 50 or 60 years old, poster from the
American Cancer Society.
And we're justifiably excited about this technological leap that
could enable us to find cancers that don't have existing screening tests,
many of which are kind of intractable, and there's really hope that early
detection will change that.
And the third
reason here is that we are optimists.
If we think we extrapolate from diagnostic performance
to expectation of benefit. If a test can find the
cancer, the test should be able to save that cancer.
And we know better.
I think
I'm not even going to go through these counters, but the world
doesn't know better. The person on the street does not know better, the person
who's going to be making decisions about how to screen in this new
era.
And
I have to start with the tale of ovarian cancer because
I began my career working on CA125.
I was fascinated by biomarkers for cancer
screening. It was the first biomarker, but really there was no data because ovarian
cancer is so rare. And fortunately, I turned around and there was another
biomarker, PSA, and I spent much of my career working on prostate
cancer. The issues of biomarkers, how you can use biomarkers,
the options that you have when using biomarkers to screen, how to
optimize that, how to understand how biomarkers
evolve over time with disease, natural history, all of that was fascinating to
me. But ovarian cancer is a poster child because there was a great
biomarker, and it was made even better by the development of a personalized
test, the ROCA algorithm, that had fantastic diagnostic performance
and ultimately made it to a large screening trial in the United Kingdom.
Two screening arms, one that used the ROCA algorithm, the
CA125 MMS, mixed modality, CA125
followed by ultrasound, and an ultrasound arm only,
and none of them showed mortality benefit.
And it's so poignant because right at the time that this trial was published and
showed that our optimism about benefit
based on performance had not borne out, right at that point of
disappointment, the hype cycle about multi-cancer early
detection started. And I kept saying, "We need to figure out what went wrong
in that trial, before we launch." And so
for the next several years, we tried to figure out what went wrong in that trial.
Which, by the way, was a fantastic success as a trial, provided incredible
information, made me think, "What makes a successful
trial?" We can talk about that.
So, three lessons in the short time that I have.
How do we go from hype to hope? How do we go from having our heads in the
clouds to our feet in the ground and making good decisions going forward?
Because harm of a test is not just the individual harm.
Harm is also system and societal harm, of putting out a test that
actually you think will work and doesn't work.
That is not good for our health system, and it's not good for society.
Maybe not bad at the individual level, having a useless test, but
very bad for society, particularly if they're related to the costs.
So, how do we keep our feet on the ground?
The first one is about diagnostic performance.
The diagnostic performance studies are dizzying, is so hard
to know what to make of a diagnostic performance study.
Then, once we kind of really understand what we need to know and take
out of these diagnostic studies,
can we predict whether finding a cancer will help a cancer?
What's going to bridge from performance to, I'll just say down staging
to earlier to diagnosis. And finally, we need to know
how to interpret studies with down staging outcomes, because the gallery trial is
really the first randomized efficacy trial with a down staging
outcome rather than mortality. And we have not been
in that game until now, and we have got a lot to learn.
Okay, diagnostic performance statistics, dizzying. They can really feed the hype.
I'm telling you this from experience.
I speak to many reporters. I'm always giving them diagnostic performance
statistics lessons.And one, I don't have time to talk
about all of these, but the one that I think is really confounding for people
is the positive predictive value versus sensitivity.
The formula's at the bottom. One is the flip side of the other.
One is the probability of cancer given you have a test, and the other is the
probability you have a positive test, probability you have a positive test given
that you have cancer.
How can the public navigate this, right?
So cancer cases are a small minority of individuals tested, and it is very
important when you put your net into that pool to diagnose individuals that you
don't net too many non-cancers. And the PPV tells
you how successful you've been with that.
The PPV is how well you've done in the non-cancers, not pulling them
out along with the cancers. But sensitivity is
how you're doing with the cancers.
Have you found them, and have you found them early?
And here's an example of how confused people get.
Headline, experimental blood test shows promise for detecting cancers earlier.
Entire article is about the PPV.
You would be forgiven for thinking that the sensitivity of the test in Pathfinder 2
was 60%. In fact, overall, it was 40%.
In that set of cancers that Peter talked about was a subset of the
cancers.
Okay? That over all the cancers, it was 40%.
Of a smaller subset, it was higher.
The point is that you could be forgiven for thinking that the test was
60% sensitive from this article.
Now, sensitivity, which really is the key, can be so
confusing. And Peter talked about sensitivity being a challenge
because sensitivity really depends on the type of study that you're doing
and the mix of cancers and the mix of stages of those
cancers. So this is one test, the Galleri
test, three studies, diagnostic test, where you
have basically a convenient sample of cases, you know they have
cancer,
and see a sensitivity aggregate overall, 51%.
Obviously, you have per cancer sensitivity.
You have per stage sensitivity, which you can get from this kind of study.
This is an
abstract ASCO by Patel,
et al.,
that was one year before diagnosis, and this is Pathfinder
overall. And so Pathfinder is an intended use
population. Asymptomatic people come get screened, follow for a
year and see, and estimate a sensitivity from
that design and that mix of cancers and that population.
And you can see we have apples and oranges here.
Very, very difficult for the public to understand sensitivity when
there's multiple different measures of sensitivity.
We have a paper where we say, "Let's figure out a new
lexicon for sensitivity, different terms for
each type." Now, what really matters with benefit?
What matters is you need early-stage sensitivity in the intended use
population. Guess what? You can't easily measure it.
This is a version of sensitivity overall.
It's actually a proxy for sensitivity.
There is no stage-specific version of that.
Very, very hard. All we really have stage-specific and cancer type-specific
is to go back to the diagnostic studies, which may well be overly
optimistic.
So out of all of this, we have to get a sense of what are we really
talking about in terms of sensitivity,
early-stage sensitivity.
And do we think that that's going to be potentially beneficial?
That's what's key for clinical benefit.
But now we have to take that and think about,
is it going to give us downstaging?
Even if we have a value of 74%,
which I think was actually
influenced by stage mix. I
don't know. We don't know what the stage of those cancers were, but I think that
later stage cancers will lead to, if you have a pool of later stage cancers, you'll
have higher sensitivity. What drives translation from performance to
downstaging?
Natural history. What's going on beneath the hood?
I got to introduce this jargon because I'll probably use it
later, the sojourn time, which is the time from
detectable onset to diagnosis. That's kind of the general
opportunity for detecting a cancer before it presents.
But what we want is the early stage opportunity, the opportunity in early
stage.
How do we learn about opportunity?
We compare
incidents. We look at the change in incidents under screening.
Can everyone guess what this cancer is?
Right, that's prostate cancer after the introduction of PSA.
This is a hypothetical screening trial where you've got interval and
screen-detected cases. And when you see how incidence changes
under screening, that tells you about what's going on beneath the hood.
Incidence changes a lot. There's a lot of prevalent cancer.
There's a long opportunity for detection.
But we want early-stage opportunity.
So we need incidence patterns by stage. And so we...
I'm going to keep going. We need incidence patterns by stage.
So we need to have screened cohorts to learn this.
And so this is work that we did in the UKC-TOCS trial, where we looked
at incidence patterns for early and late.
Here we've got two arms, the mixed modality and ultrasound,
and we have screen-detected cancers,
early and late, and interval-detected cancers, early and late.
And then we can learn the early stage opportunity, the duration that the
cancer spends in early stage, and we can also learn the
late stage opportunity, how long the cancer is in late stage.
This turns out to be important, too.
This is work by my brilliant colleague, Jane Lang.
In the UKC-TOCS trial, there was, particularly in high-grade
serious cancers, which are the majority of cancers and the most lethal of cancers,
the early stage opportunity to detect disease was less than four months.
The late stage was long.The sensitivity was very high,
but it was such a short time that they were really early, that
translated into no mortality benefit.
We could not shift cases out into the earliest
stages because they just did not spend enough time
there. Okay, so even a high
sensitivity test may not downstage if the opportunity is short.
And we don't know the opportunity before we screen, so we're
guessing. We know the opportunity for cancers for which we've done screening.
For cancers that we haven't done screening, we're guessing.
And this now becomes important in studies with downstaging
outcomes. And this is the way that the field
appears to be going. Traditional screening trials were to mortality.
The gallery trial is precedent setting.
It's going to look at the reduction in late-stage incidents.
This has been a major topic of discussion in the field over the last
year or so. Sorry, last year or three,
where we've seen many studies looking back at trials that have been
done and looking at whether late stage...
Those of you that know clinical literature will recognize this, whether the
putative surrogate endpoint, late-stage reduction,
correlates well with the actual endpoint, mortality reduction.
And this is across prior trials. And the results have
been quite suggestive that there's a correlation in these, but it
varies across cancer types, and it's very unclear that it
will extend to cancers for which we have
never screened for, because it's variable across cancer types.
And this is a big topic, an active discussion, lots of work going on
in this area. But we're moving forward.
Now, it turns out I don't have time to talk about all the complexities of
these trials, but I'm going to give you a little window into why there's more than
meets the eye. Here's a model of the projected
late-stage reduction with a two-year mean sojourn time.
We've reduced the sensitivity per cancer.
This is a multi-cancer test for those 12 cancers that Peter talked about,
0.5 times the diagnostic sensitivity.
This is the reduction in late stage, the percent reduction over
three years, when late stage is stage four.
So we've assumed that it's about six months duration.
If late stage is six months duration, we get about a 20%
reduction under these conditions across these 12 cancers
in late stage over three years. But if late
stage is three plus four, so we take the duration equal to one year,
for example, turns out if late stage is one year, then when
you do a screening test, there's going to be a whole lot of late-stage cases
that are prevalent, and they're going to make your incidence of
late stage in the screen arm more than in your control arm.
You have a negative late-stage reduction.
Then you have to start making it up in later screens, and by three years, you
haven't gotten very far. Probably to see a late-stage reduction with a
three plus four, you need to go a little longer and see how
well you can do.
Two more minutes.
Yeah, don't worry.
Okay. And that basically explains, I haven't seen the
results, but qualitatively explains,
why three plus four, the endpoint of three plus four was
not reached, but an endpoint of four was reached.
Okay, so what does this mean clinically?
The question that I've been asked by so many people since
the publicizing of these results is, what does it mean for clinical
utility?
And it's very challenging, right?
Because if you want to talk about stage four, it looks great.
If you want to talk about stage three plus four, it doesn't look so good.
Just like diagnostic studies, you can present different statistics, and they're
going to tell you different stories.
And this is where hype comes from, where you can kind of selectively
present something that fits a message that you want to put out.
So I just will say that it's very challenging to interpret a late-stage
reduction. We actually don't know how to do it. It depends on late stage.
If anyone talks to you about late-stage reduction, the first question, what is late
stage, right?
And it's a big conundrum how to interpret.
We want to get on terra firma. Let's think about how we can link
this to mortality. Can we predict a mortality reduction from a late-stage
reduction? This is a schematic. Our stage has changed.
People move from late to early. We combine that with some estimate of
stage-specific survival, usually taken from data without screening, which
is an assumption and has issues, and we project the effect on
mortality. There is much work to be done here.
It's a model. It's a predictive model, so it depends on the inputs and the
assumptions. You can do this many different ways, and you'll get
different answers. So when you see a predicted mortality from a late-stage
reduction, the first question is: how did they do it? What were the assumptions?
I think that we are in a challenging time in terms of how do we
contextualize these kinds of results for clinical utility.
And that's why, as we go towards hope, I want to publicize a forthcoming report
from the American Cancer Society, where we sat down, Peter was
there, and we sat down around a table with experts in the
field to try to lay out all the issues that
people should consider when
designing, how long the trial should be, reporting, and
interpreting results from late-stage incidence trials, and that should be out,
hopefully soon. So to go from hype to hope in multi-cancer early detection,
I think
getting our feet firmly on the ground so that we are putting out something that has
real hope for patients, better understanding diagnostic performance measures,
acknowledging that translation to benefit is not automatic,
and all of these are challenging things to try to then fill in the gaps,
right? And then recognizing that downstaging studies may feed the hype cycle if we
don't ask the right questions. I want to thank my colleagues, my brilliant
colleague, Raman Gulati, Jane Lange,
my guru, Noel Weiss.And American Cancer Society
workshop participants, RALE for putting out all those studies that allowed us
to poke them, and all of my support.
Thank you.
My turn. So I agree with many of the things that Peter
and Ruth said, and I will try to give the perspective of, I
guess I maybe represent people who actually technically
develop those tests, and
kind of tell you how we're thinking about it
and what it means.
So those are my disclosures, present and past.
And I like this cartoon, I know many of you have seen it.
So I'll have a mix of positive and maybe
negative things, but it says... I'm the old man right there
in front of the pearly gates and saying that, "I had been here
sooner if it hadn't been for early detection." And really, in a
way, that's what they're trying to do.
Of course, you can
die from other reasons, but cancer, as we know, is the number two and soon to
become number one killer. And the way I
think about early detection is that being proactive about the
disease and actually trying to address
under-diagnosis. I know we talk a lot about over-diagnosis,
and that's real, but under-diagnosis is real, too.
And that most of the deaths nowadays that we have is for cancers,
others here in the United States or in Europe or in Japan or
Asia, they are
from cancers that we do not have a standard of care to screen.
Now, even us that we develop this test, it doesn't
escape our
attention, the complexity of having the
challenges for having an early detection test to be developed.
There are social challenges. Each one of those, and there are more,
may require its own forum, but I just wanted to mention that
those are things in our minds, too.
Psychological issues, how you communicate the
data, positive can give anxiety, although I
get anxiety for any test, not only for diagnosis.
And negative results also, they may make you have a false sense of
security that you may not have cancer.
Performance, I think, is very important, and I know already
both Peter and
Ruth talked about sensitivity, and PPVs and all these
things. But that is something that
it's in a way our job to try to develop tests that make
sense for the populations we want to
screen. And of course, there are economical issues and there are practical issues
of trying to approach and have these tests available to
many individuals. But in a positive view, the way I see this,
there is a window of opportunity to do things with intent to cure.
That's the goal, at least, of detecting something at the stage
that we call it early stage or earlier than we can detect it
now, that actually we can do something, and it will require surgeries or therapies,
but with intent to cure. This is all the data and from another
different, it's not for early
stage. But also, it's becoming obvious,
I do not know a systematic review or anything, but if you look at trials
for other reasons, the smaller the number of cells you have to
kill, the low-burden tumors, and that kind of goes with what
we traditionally call part of the stage in tumors, the
easier it is to kill. This is for colorectal cancer,
30% or so, or 25% of them can be cured by
systemic therapy, the other 25%
with surgery. Of course, this is not the same for every
tumor type, but it's a numbers game, too, when
earlier stage cancers, they have fewer cells that you need to kill.
So the hope of the multi-cancer detection, at least in my mind, is to detect
more cancers in addition to the standard of care.
Right now, I don't see the replacing of the standard of care.
Fewer individuals to screen to detect cancer, and I think
cumulatively, a better false positive rate and a
better PPV than multiple tests that's
administered at the same individual, one, let's say, for
ovarian, one for pancreas, one so on.
So where are we, or what we know about it, and I'll
try to be brief about that. We know that with one blood
draw, we can detect a lot of different tumor types.
Is it feasible? And I think
the only
way to do this is to have prospective studies.
Usually, the cancers in these prospective studies in the target population, they
have smaller in size tumors, earlier stage cancers, that's why they have not been
detected. Interventional studies, because they're going to tell
you how much harm you do or how much good perhaps you do,
and what is the odyssey of these individuals.
And also follow-up, long-term follow-up of the people who had positive and
negative results, so you can understand how this management has
affected their lives. DetectA, if you guys went
to Tom's excellent talk yesterday, you heard a lot.
All I want to mention it because this is one of those prospective
interventional studies. Imperfect, I know.
We did that years ago in 10,000 women and
included also, once you get the test,
a multidisciplinary committee decides if you need a follow-up
with imaging. So diagnostic imaging was performed.
Another point there with
looking at the imaging, you can actually determine if really, in
some cases, if you need to continue with some intervention, which it can
be
surgery, chemotherapy, radiation therapy.
And,
fortunately, at least with true positives, we
have follow-up, and I said this, that's important.
Not surprisingly, after
4.4 or I think it's 4.7 actually years, the ones that they
were stage I and II, they were cancer free,
and nobody died. And not surprisingly, again, the ones that
they were deemed stage IV, and that's from different type of tumors, most
of them were deceased.Pathfinder, I don't need to touch those,
but those are also some studies you heard about.
I mention it there for completeness because I wanted to get to that.
I think those studies that have been done to this point is
also Ruth said, yeah, we poke on them, and that is very correctly.
But I think they taught us a couple of things, at least in our mind, that it could
be feasible. We're not ready yet, but it could be feasible
to actually detect cancers and
do things, manage these individuals with intent to cure, but also need to
be very careful paired with diagnostic tests.
A liquid biopsy test, it tells you that maybe there is a signal for
cancer there. It's not a diagnostic test in itself.
The other question that we wanted at least to ask to make it worth continuing
developing those tests was how long before diagnosis can detect that.
And, with Elizabeth Platz at Hopkins
and Yusen Wan, an
assistant professor, we tapped into a unique, I think,
resource. It's called ARIC. These individuals, as you can see at the lower
part here, since the '80s actually, they were giving blood that it
was stored to really look for risk of atherosclerosis.
Of course, some of them came up with cancer, and then first we wanted to see,
can we detect them? These cancers were not detected within a
study for cancer. They were detected because of symptoms, because
of other reasons that these people went to the doctor.
And,
we detected a number of them between zero and six months
before
the diagnosis. And then we went farther, since we had the
availability of the plasma, to three years.
And we can go farther down, if we can, to actually
see if the same mutations were actually present three years before
diagnosis as they were present zero to six months before diagnosis.
And the answer was yes, indicating that we can detect
them. And they were not from a certain tumor type.
They were different tumor types that we detected in different
stages. But also, I need to mention something that it was mentioned.
Those tests do not have the same sensitivity,
and this is from a case control study.
But again, it demonstrates the point or the issue that we have to be careful.
Sensitivity varies from cancer type to cancer type.
And as Ruth and Peter mentioned, and I'll mention,
actually, it varies also from stage to stage, and especially
stage I. This is where we want to actually find those cancers,
and the sensitivity is not very high.
So what we need, I think a test that has high
specificity for the clinical
application screening that we're talking about is important,
and sensitivity for early cancer providing a chance for better
outcome. And usually, when we develop the test, we have an ROC
curve, which
they're very, very useful. But we like to actually first say
what should be the specificity or the appropriate sensitivity for,
in this case, screening the average risk individual.
If it's a high risk, actually, you can have the same test and change
the specificity to lower in order to increase sensitivity, assuming that
these people, anyway, they're undergoing some follow-up
procedures, so you don't add more to them.
And
so I was asking myself, what is a good
sensitivity for cancers without a standard of
care screening? And with that, I mean not overall, a sensitivity for early
stages, stage I and II. Right now, for these cancers, we
really have zero. And
I was wondering, what would be acceptable?
And we can discuss, is it 20%, 30%? What
percent, at least for version one of those tests,
if you wish, is going to make us think that it's something?
Because really, for some cases, we detect zero, so anything will be
better. Now, the positive predictive value is going to really
be different depending on the population that you
administer this test.
One thing also that we learned, which I thought it was important about the zero to
six months versus
three
years detecting the same cancers, and you can see one in blue and the other one
with red, is that the amount of circulating tumor
DNA or MAF, mutational allele fraction, is
really, really low. And those are the same
mutations. So the same tumor type or clone is present over
those three years.
And it grows, and it creates more cells, and that's why we see more
of it the closer we get to the diagnosis.
But this also tells us that we really need to develop technologies with
high sensitivity without affecting the specificity.
I know that Peter mentioned 0.1%. I think that we
have to get better in order for those tests to be
applicable. And I think we use proteins, too, and I don't think
they have even close the sensitivity to get close to
that. So how do we do this? To put a little bit of what we do is,
circulating tumor DNA, in this case, they have so many different features, if you
wish, and usually we develop machine learning in order to try to make
sense of that and develop models for stratification.
That is very challenging. Every
feature, whatever you're going to call your circulating DNA,
fragmentomics, mutations, methylation that we're trying to combine,
they are actually, each one brings issues, especially with the
specificity. And very briefly, I think we need to be asking the
questions, and those are people that work with us,
Josh, Sam, and Chris, and they are really spending their time doing the
following. We do need machine learning and algorithms to interpret
this data from circulating tumor DNA.
But I'm tired of seeing papers that from the same groups even, and I
don't exclude ourselves, where you develop a test
and an algorithm, and then you go to the next cohort, and you have to train it
again. So we need to develop algorithms that actually we can really trust
them, that they have rigorous confidence
limits.Identify which of these markers are more
informative, not just blindly put them in.
And they have to be specific to cancer.
Like for example, fragmentomics recently, we know they are not necessarily
specific to cancer, still can be useful in the right
context, but that's how at least we're thinking as we develop the test.
So what we need, I think we need prospective interventional trials to evaluate the
utility of this test. I don't have to
reiterate that. But these trials, they have to be, and that's where I kind of
agree with Peter, in some reasonable timeframe.
Now, I don't know if it's going to be, and we have to decide as a community, is it
higher number of true early-stage cancers?
And again, I remind everybody that
early-stage cancer for
colon cancer, stage III might be early enough to manage them, but not
for pancreatic cancer, for example.
Intend to cure with management, maybe
follow up with minimal residual disease to prove that
the tumor is really gone after the management.
Cancer-specific mortality, I do not know.
And I'm not going to mention the Galleri study or
NIH, because already has been mentioned.
And of course, those studies need to be done in target population.
The other thing that we're not going to discuss today is we can
detect the cancer, we still need better therapies.
So just detecting the cancer, it doesn't mean much if we
don't have ways to actually manage those individuals.
So as final thoughts, and then we open it to discussion, is
the tests are coming. Actually, some of them are here.
I have two examples, the Galleri, the exact test, so people can actually take
them, and also, we heard a lot about the studies.
We need to evaluate them appropriately, but in a reasonable
timeframe. And finally, tests that do not
focus on performance reasonable for the clinical
application, in this case, we're talking about screening, I think they're
going to poison the field. If you have tests that they have
certain specificity, I don't know, 60%, whatever, for this population,
is not going to work. So I think if those
tests like this going into the trial, I think all they're going to do is
they're going to poison the field.
So it is a complicated
field
as we're trying to develop those tests and a lot of
collaborators. And thank you for your attention, and now we can
open this to discussion. Thank you.
Maybe I can stay here.
Anybody, any questions? Tom is laughing.
I have a lot to say.
You have a lot to say. So why don't you pick up the microphone?
Yeah.
Right here.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, no problem.
See, I looked to my left over there.
Yeah. Hi.
Hi.
Chin Hur, Columbia University in New York. Hi, Ruth.
Great session. Appreciate everything.
And Peter, before I get to my question, appreciate the
aspect of underprivileged and the access
democratization. I think that's a very compelling argument.
So my question is,
a lot of this is,
I think this is Ruth's argument, which I agree with, is we can't really handle
the harms. harms and benefits, obviously, it's
in the same
pot, but the harms. And I think, let me boil it down very
simply. What are the harms? There's the disutility
of false positives and early positives, and then there's
costs. That's largely societal, right? Overutilization.
And I think that this is another dimension, this
is actually a question.
I think it really depends on the cancer, and I think perhaps my colleague, Ruth,
is overly skeptical, perhaps, because she started in
cancers where screening was not a good idea, let's face it,
right? Prostate cancer, majority of men will die with
prostate cancer. Ovarian cancer is just very difficult.
And so I think the key thing is someone who's
a gastroenterologist in, for example, colon cancer,
that the reason even if you get false positives,
it's okay,
is because you have such a good confirmatory test
that even if you have a false positive, the colonoscopy has enough
sensitivity specificity. And so I think
the real estate has to be cancer-specific,
largely based on the performance of the confirmatory test.
So just throw that out there to see what people in the panel think about that.
So
I would agree that the acceptable PPV depends on what
happens next. And so if you've got a tissue
of origin part of your test,
you should be looking at the PPV for each
potential result of the test separately,
and then say how good does it need to be.
And it doesn't need to be very good for colorectal, because
in America, you're happy to do a colonoscopy with less than a
1% chance of finding a cancer. So
that's a PPV of 1%, it's horrendous.
For a chest CT, it doesn't need to be very high.
For ovarian cancer, the PPV needs to be pretty high because if
what you're going to do is operate and biopsy
the ovaries or remove the ovaries, you don't want to be getting that very wrong.
And in the ultrasound arm of UK CTOC,
I think the lesson we should have learned was we should have stopped that
immediately because we were operating
on three or four women to find one cancer.
Well, we weren't, but they were.
I don't know. You mentioned your name, that's why.
I don't know if you want to-
Yeah.
Oh, I just want to say that the prostate cancer and ovarian are so interesting
because they're completely opposite.
Ovarian has a very short opportunity.
The test that we had had high sensitivity,
but over a very short opportunity in early stage.
Whereas prostate cancer actually had low sensitivity.
Ian Thompson's study of the
PCPT showed that the test had very poor sensitivity, something like
25%.
But it had so much time that you had a few
opportunities, and that then actually made prostate cancer
screening very effective, but of course, with a high downside
that then had to be managed. And I will say that one
thing that I learned from prostate cancer that I think is going to be true of any
new technology, is that the first 20 years of prostate cancer screening in the
population were an experiment. The first
chunk of time that you bring a new cancer screening test into the population, you
are in an experiment. You don't know that much about natural history.
Things emerge that you never expected.
The over-diagnosis with prostate cancer screening,
maybe we should have expected, but we hadn't done prostate cancer screening, so we
didn't know as much as we know now. And so through that
experiment, we got better. But I would just say, Nick, you put up the pictures of
the products. Everyone who takes one of these tests, you should know that you're in
an experiment. Maybe not a-
Yeah
... controlled experiment, but you're a guinea pig at this point,
I think.
I didn't put them for advertisement.
No, I'm just saying that anyone.
Yes.
All of the
more tests that are going to come out.
No, but you are there, and I think people need to...
Yeah, I understand now what you're saying. And just very briefly.
Yeah.
I think we agree on that, and I tried to mention the talk that,
yes, not every cancer that we type has the
same. Some of them are going to be managed differently than others.
And that is one of the things that we have to learn in some cases.
That's why I said also we need better therapies, we need better management.
It really is complicated in that. That doesn't mean that we need to stop
developing those tests to try to detect them. It has to be in parallel.
Yeah. I'm
taking a lot of time, but I think the summary is the harms are a
little more well understood and perhaps less when you have a
good confirmatory test. That's my summary.
Let's say we design an MCED.
If you want to do minimize harm and the uncertainty around it,
that's the way to do it. And I think a shotgun
approach with 50 cancers is not a good idea, because I'm in Ruth's camp
overall about the concerns about harms. That's my argument.
Yeah. Just one more thing. I agree, but also the
performance of the test before you get to the confirmatory or whatever the
follow-up, that has to be appropriate for the clinical application.
I don't think we are there yet in terms of having a real sensitivity
for early stages.
No, no, no.
And the specificity that is required.
Yeah, no. Absolutely. Of course, sensitivity is the most important. Well, valuable.
But I'm getting at the uncertainty of the-
I just think that-
Are we going to go left or right?
The bit I really disagree with is that we shouldn't be looking at multi-cancer
tests. Tests that can find pretty much all
types of cancer. That is the only way we're going to be able to
do anything for rare cancers. And
a lot of the signals are very common across all cancers.
So you can't say, "I'm looking for cell-free DNA, and now I'm
only going to restrict it." So the recent NCI
paper said that all these tests that said, "Oh, we're only looking for six
cancers," actually were picking up cancers from other types
that were included in the study. So you have
sensitivity across the board if you're using these
multi-cancer tests or these technologies.
And you've got to work out how to manage that.
You can't ignore the fact. And if you just go, "Well, I only want
single site screening," well,
the only thing we've got in the last 30 years is lung.
That is not the way to make progress.
Single site, I agree with you that single site, I will
see it more like if you want bladder cancer, but you use urine, not
necessarily blood. There could be high-risk individuals
or maybe saliva for head and neck and there is a place for
that, too. But I agree with you. The signals,
mutations, fragmentomics, methylation, they are common among
cancers. So if you say, "I want to find only pancreatic cancer," let's
say, you're going to find more breast cancers, for example, if it's a
BRCA mutation. So yeah, I agree. Tom.
I have a dozen comments, but I'll try to limit it to three.
Just for fun. So three
things that I wanted to talk about.
One is
risks or hazards of MCEDs, and that's a very important
area for us to focus on. But I think we need to be a little more
rigorous and serious about it than the discussion, not today, but in the
field has been. We talk about things like anxiety.
We're not seeing evidence of that.
Every medical test makes you anxious when you're not sure what the result is.
I get my lipid panel. When my cholesterol is high, I get anxious.
This is not unique to MCED. So the emphasis on
that, I think, is
probably a little bit overblown.
False negatives and reassurance.
So the big harm here is happily living
thinking you don't have cancer even though you might.
That's really only harmful if you skip screenings.
That's the risk. Otherwise,
having a screening test that yields a negative result
even though eventually you get a cancer, is not really a meaningful harm
to people. And it's true of any screening test anyway.
I think the real harms come from false
positivesThe ensuing workup,
complications of the workup,
and if the behavior of screened individuals
really is modified so that they skip effective screening, and
that's really what we need to focus on.
My second comment is,
I love Ruth's talk about what we can learn from UKC
talks. I would love the same amount of attention
on what went right in NLST, in the fecal
occult blood test studies,
because screening does work. We're here because for
multiple cancer screening works, there's lots of reasons why
it's difficult in ovarian cancer.
It's actually been successful in prostate cancer, to my previous
questioner. It took us a long time to figure it out.
But in RSPEC, there's a 20% mortality reduction from
prostate cancer screening. So this idea that prostate cancer screening is a
failure is patently incorrect, and I just have to say that as a
prostate oncologist. So let's focus on what went right.
And many of the cancers we're looking for are more like colorectal
cancer than ovarian cancer. Esophageal, gastric.
There's some real opportunities there.
And my last comment is, I think we need to be Bayesian in our
thinking as a society. The price for absolute certainty is
astronomical. It would take 20 years and
many lives lost, as Peter said.
We don't want to be careless,
but we have to accept the idea that
we'll have some probability as we
start implementing these tests that they're going to be successful and they're
going to help, and then we're going to continue to learn.
And, we make very few decisions in life with absolute certainty of what the
outcome's going to be. So if we want to wait for 20 years, I don't
think any of us want that. I think we need to get to a level of confidence
that these tests are likely to be helpful and get going, and
then continue to learn.
So Tom, thanks, but
I agree with you, especially with the last comment.
What will give you confidence?
I know you're supposed to ask the question to us, but it's
a discussion.
Yeah.
You got me up here, so I think, yeah.
That's a million-dollar question.
I think
we're working very hard in designing our
upcoming prospective study,
with endpoints that we hope to be meaningful to convince
us and convince everybody else that there's a
benefit. And I think it's going to be a combination of
a comparison of the number of folks who have the
opportunity to have curative therapy,
for their cancer post-diagnosis.
The initial outcome of therapy, how many folks are rendered disease-free with
therapy. I think some measure of reduction in Stage 4
disease, with all the attendant uncertainties about
what that will translate to in the long
run. And, I think we're going to put that body of
knowledge together, look at it and say, "Yeah, this
looks good enough." I don't think it's any one endpoint that we
can measure a priority. We would like to do a
nested mortality analysis. That's going to take some time.
We may be underpowered for it, and so we may have to accept a point
estimate with wide confidence intervals
as part of a broader clinical utility package.
But I'm wide open to advice. We're still designing it, and there's room for
input.
Thanks.
Thank you. Very nice session.
Some practical questions. Since I'm in the directorate
of the largest Italian cancer comprehensive center, and I'm fond
of MCAD since a couple of years. And the
points are,
the gallery story tells us that we need to do more
research anyway.
And the points they tell me from the management
is, how do we recruit
the people to test if they are not at risk?
We want to screen also healthy populations, and they don't come to our
institutions. We have to have interactions with
other structures or just a normal practitioner for
conscious.
The second is that the studies are very important
for our future also,
students, if you do
good biobanking. And you need large numbers.
You see that if you have results, if you have 20,000 people.
So you have to find a way to store, maybe for every
sample, you have to fractionate it.
So you need infrastructures for that.
And then it's also the cost, because if I do it as a study and I have
to do, let's say, 10,000 people, and every test
costs €500 maybe or
whatever, then I need
sponsorship for $5 million.
So those are practical points to make a study.
So what are the points, particular for instance, from the UK?
So we're in the European thing to do,
multicentric, having
large infrastructures and also collect things like...
We have lots of epidemiological data from the Nurse Health Study,
which is very old. So we also have to think to the future.
So we want the result immediately, but also having
the possibility to go back when some marker is found and
see how this has been working. So basically, the points are how to
recruit the patients, how to pay for the study, and how
to biobank the samples.
I can try.
So, in academia, we don't have millions,
right? And just for reference, the Detect-A study,
as you know, NIH doesn't fund those things.
We had to go and raise money from private donors
to do it, and
I'm storing 10,000 samples from that study, and
it's a pain, and I don't know if all of them will survive.
Yeah, it's expensive, so you need infrastructure, at least in
academia,
up to a point. We cannot do 140,000 people,
that's for sure, but we need the support from, in that case, got the support
from Hopkins at least to have a biobank.
And I think a lot of times, either within liquid biopsy
consortium or other entities, people can
potentially contribute to this type of biobanks.
But this is not going to get us to the next step.
Perhaps, people like GRAIL, Exact,
those companies, those are the ones that they're going to be able, potentially, to
do big studies. This is my perspective, what
we went through with the Detect-A, and it's not something that
we can repeat it
in a larger scale. So I don't know what Peter you have-
Probably also the right way to do is like the Vanguard, a little
bit comparing, having the chance to have two or three
different tests or do multi-model.
So it's a sort of a dream
trial.
Again,
Christos can actually fill us in on that and how you get
the funding to do this. But Peter, go ahead for-
So
briefly, on the
recruitment and reaching people, I think it was key that we used mobile
units so that we went to where people are.
We took into supermarkets, car parks, and
stadium car parks.
We worked with communities, local communities.
So I think you can do things, and there's a paper
that describes some of the things we did there.
And
NHS-Galleri was funded by GRAIL exclusively,
except that
once people
had a positive test and then had to have diagnostic work-up, and certainly if
they had treatment, that was all paid for by the NHS.
So that became under the state system.
So
having that mixed model,
I think thinking about the design, so we're doing esophageal
screening, we're doing prostate screening, both of which are funded by
the research sector.
And
thinking about how to
minimize the size of the trial and still get informative
results.
There are disadvantages in the esophageal.
We wanted to collect bloods on everyone.
We could only afford to get dry blood spots because they cost almost nothing to
store. So,
there are trade-offs.
I sometimes think if the study's big enough,
you might then be able to get separate funding for the biobanking.
But I do wonder whether the
advantage of that biobanking in a
randomized controlled study is so much greater than just doing these very
large cohort studies with serial collection.
It would be great if you could always
evaluate more than one screening test in the same study, like Vanguards do,
but there are huge disadvantages because most companies don't want to be doing
that, which means you're going to have to fund it with public money.
And in the UK, I cannot imagine,
we could never have afforded to do a study like NLST on
public money and certainly couldn't have done GRAIL.
So there are trade-offs in terms of what you can get
out of any study. But happy to chat to you later.
Oh, okay. I came up after one or two of those people, but-
No, left and right.
Left and right. Okay. I'm Chris Berg.
I
was the NCI lead on a $250 million study, the
National Lung Screening Trial. So I was accused of lowering the
pay line for the NIH.
And my question, though, is
stage as an endpoint. There's now been three
meta-analyses,
looking at stage tracking with a reduction in advanced
stage disease and subsequent outcome with mortality.
Ruth put up a slide looking at the first round of screening
is really finding all the prevalent cases.
Could a
new meta-analysis be done of the 39
trials that
Lou used, of the results from
the incidence rounds of screening to see if the
stage change
correlates better with mortality?
Would that be reasonable?
If you only do the incidence rounds of screening, so you basically drop the cases-
Right, from the prevalent round.
Yeah, but then you have to drop those cases out of the control arm, too.
Right.
And Noel Weiss actually
addressed this, actually in the case of colorectal
screening, where your outcome is incidence, not
mortality, then you have the same problem.
The first screening test, if you have cancer at the first screening test, you can't
be helped.
Right.
And you want to drop. And so he proposed, let's drop however many cases you have in
the screen arm on the first screen, drop them, and drop a similar number of cases
from the control arm.
Now, you could go back and do those meta-analyses
again. What is clear is that's going to give you a more
powerful test, a more powerful comparison.
I think that the meta-analyses are fine to do, but they're
really a blunt instrument. Peter has a nice new paper about
these kinds of studies.
You could
actually have a reallya good correlation in
theory, but not see it in practice.
Yeah.
Because these are such apples and oranges, these trials.
I'm going to let Peter talk about his paper.
So I'm not inclined to do another meta-analysis after Peter's paper, but
I am inclined to propose what we're calling a prevalence
adjusted comparison for these trials, where you take out those
prevalent cases. But I don't know what Peter thinks about that, or you feel free to
weigh in.
I think one of the issues is that many of the trials,
I don't think anyone's got the data anymore. It's disappeared.
Certainly, it's impossible for people who want to do individual patient
meta-analysis to get hold of it. So-
The NLST and PLCO data are all-
No.
Okay. So we're doing a variety of
analysis on NLST and PLCO
and hopefully UK CTOC. And so for
instance, looking at predicted
mortality
over time
and how well it predicts, at what point it starts predicting the end
results of the trial pretty well.
The trouble is
you can't really conclude anything from five trials or whatever it is you can
get data from.
But those things are happening.
The issue is that,
as Ruth shows with her modeling,
if you want to show a reduction
in harms, you've got to wait quite a long time.
What I think she didn't point out was that it's a time after the last
screen rather than longer time, because every time
you screen, you're going to find more of those stage three cancers that you're
picking up, and so
you've got to wait longer again. So I'm not convinced that if you continue to do
modeling for seven rounds, but you're still only looking for a year
after the last screen, you're going to get much of a reduction in stage three
cancers. You've got to stop and wait.
But that doesn't mean that the mortality benefit wouldn't start happening earlier
with more rounds of screening.
Can I ask?
Probably this is going to...
I was trying to find for a long time data, but maybe they're there, about
the ovarian study in the UK.
So
having in what at least in our hands is not as sensitive, there were a
lot of stage one that were called. How many of these individuals
had surgery, but then they died from ovarian cancer?
Were they cured? I couldn't find this data. Where was the follow-up?
So I don't have access to the data, so it's not actually in the public
domain.
They do have a paper
in which you can see how many people had
minimal residual disease
between arms, after surgery,
which it's quite interesting there, and that makes a big, big difference.
Yeah. The reason I'm bringing this up,
and that's why the performance of the test and what
sensitivity is.
Things that you think they are stage one, but then you do surgery
and they come back.
Those to me, they are not stage one.
Almost certainly, UK CTOCs used pathological stage,
whereas a lot of US studies use clinical stage.
But
the UK studies tend to use pathological stage.
So-
Practically what I mean, Peter, is no matter what the staging then they were called
maybe differently in different places.
I know in discussing this during this year with other people,
they say, "Well, it doesn't work because we found stage one and then people died
from the same disease." That means you missed maybe micrometastasis,
that's fine, but that's not necessarily what we would call
stage one localized cancer. And I think the
sensitivity of some of those older studies or
tests, I think they have played a role in how we interpret
some of the data.
Of course, ovarian is weird because if most ovarian cancer
is actually fallopian tube cancer, then it's all
metastasized by the time you diagnose it.
Yes. And in the United States, there's a big thing now to
have
elective
of fallopian tube, but not ovarian, actually take the ovary out.
But again, it's how we interpret the data and what
actually a test can do. That's why I think we need better tests and
with the appropriate trials in order to be able to think and
to interpret them. So yes. Sorry. Long time.
Yeah.
Hey. Payal Kincher from the National Cancer Institute at the NIH.
Thanks for this session.
While we're talking a lot about population scalability of these tests,
where I feel personally it's been really hard to garner conversation
or interest is around high-risk populations.
Some of which, whether that's germline predisposition or other high risk, where
there's the ability there, arguably the urgency, and the ability to
look at many of the things that have been listed as challenges today, whether
that's recruit ability,
established data on anxiety outcomes, whether that's down staging, treatment
mitigation,
comparisons to screening, and what the evidence is already there.
So I was curious with the panel of what the conversation has been in the field or
what the thoughts are around true MFED testing in
high-risk populations where the event rates are really high, and we're talking fast
data versus slow data, 20 years versus being able to do this
and in a smaller scale settings with more events.
But sort of to get your thoughts on where this conversation needs to go,
where that partnership needs to go, where we can really truly
establish whether that's outcome benefit, stage benefit, therapy
mitigation, whatever that outcome may be.
Well, I think the high-risk populations are a great use
case for these technologies. I think there's a lot
of growth in high-risk clinics and multi-cancer
clinics for high-risk individuals or even average risk as
well. And I think that there's an opportunity for some kind
of consortium to be developed, something like the Breast Cancer Surveillance
Consortium that was developed to
pioneer these tests and their
outcomes in these populations. And I expect that
people are thinking about that. But
that to me kind of has to happen
organically and get supported. But the Breast Cancer
Surveillance Consortium, which was a consortium of mammography facilities,
became the authoritative resource on diagnostic
performance and outcomes of mammography
over time. And so,
it's a great model potentially for somebody, an interested
person or people to follow.
Yeah.
So I'm going to disagree.
So I think it's very difficult to identify people who are at very
high risk of all cancers.
And then if you start talking about people with very high penetrance
mutations,
I don't know why you'd want a multi-cancer test.
So if you've got BRCA,
the tests at the moment are not very good for
screen-detected breast cancer.
And you're only interested in three or four cancers particularly.
That's why they're high risk.
With Lynch, there'd be more of an issue, but I think it needs to be studied more
because I think if you want a multi-cancer test for Lynch,
you probably should be thinking about, well, let's look for microsatellite
instability somehow within your test.
So I would hope, and
Nick could say this better, but I would hope you could get a better test if it's
for Lynch patients.
And the technologies at the moment do not seem to be
useful for BRCA, for instance. So I think you need to be very
careful and think about what is the technology, what's it doing, and
is it likely to be able to help that population?
But going for smokers, going for people who are overweight, who are all
at higher risk, makes perfect sense.
Yeah, Peter I agree with that. I think although the
high risk--
I'm a proponent of the multi-cancer detection,
but for high-risk individuals, we try to load the
biomarkers towards for that
particular cancer.
So
that, I think, maybe goes along to what Peter said.
So that will be tailored in a way. It's not going to be multi-cancer
detection. It's going to focus on even if we include, let's say,
proteins and mutations, we're going to select the panels that
they are actually going to increase the chance to find
this particular cancer that you look.
But that is not yet multi-cancer detection.
I know that there is, and I put this question on my slide, that a lot of people are
thinking that maybe this is where we need to start for the reasons you said.
But there are the other caveats that Peter also brought up.
So for us, if we want to divide something for high-risk
individuals, let's say for breast cancer or for pancreatic cancer,
we just
focus on that and try to have the appropriate markers to detect it with
a higher sensitivity and higher specificity, so.
Okay, I'll go there because can you wait? Of course.
Because he's been there standing for a long time. I can wait.
Yeah, I can. So, first, Nick, thank you very much, and Ruth and Peter, great
sessions.
Really appreciate it and a lot of things to think about.
One of the things,
got me in several of the comments and your talks was
democratization and use of these tests.
And I would propose that more attention should
be given to taking the ctDNA from urine,
because in every test that we have so far,
the public health benefit is proportional much more to the
percentage of the population that actually takes the test
than to the sensitivity and specificity, or I like to think of them
as the risk factor, the risk percentages that come from
them.
And so that's one thought, and the other is, I think people
make very good comments on the natural history of the disease,
the rapid progression of at least some
ovarian cancers and maybe saying all are metastatic and the natural
history and what we can do to intervene later on.
The subsequent steps are extremely important.
And very interestingly,
in both breast-- and this leads to a question finally, in both
prostate and ovarian cancer, a very fast and slow progressing
situation, the ability to follow over time
was very important.
And do we really need to be thinking about following
people as individuals over
time rather than establishing cutoffs?
So I don't know what you mean instead of rather than establishing cutoffs.
I mean, the-
Change over time in those.
Oh, I see. Okay.
It may happen,
but I think you have to start
with a cutoff,
and then the question of... But if the issue is, and I
think there's a lot of indication that there just isn't
any...
cell-free DNA from a tumor
at those earlier times, then you're not going to see that thing.
It looks to me like there's a very sudden change,
and that
it becomes detectable. So I think with other biomarkers,
that it may well be that you want to look at the profile.
Protein biomarkers, definitely.
But
Nick, what do you think?
Yeah, no, I agree. I think for the circulating tumor DNA,
it has to go with cutoff.
For minimal residual disease and monitoring, that's
what we do. We follow it, and we see actually if it's going up or
down. But that's a different setting.
This is individuals that they have cancer, and now that they get treated,
and we want to see if the treatment works or so on.
But for early detection,
we have to have a cutoff just to avoid
technical issues and false positives, technical false positives.
But if it's there, the idea is that it comes from cancer.
I think that's what also Peter was saying.
Right.
So it's in different applications like minimal
residual disease, yes, we follow that.
But for early detection, either is there and we can detect it
or not. So that's how it goes.
You disagree?
No.
Well, I really think what we're often detecting
is risk of cancer, and often
some of the sensitivity and specificity gets a little wonky
because we're talking about
the sensitivity and specificity for a future
event.
And that's not originally how diagnostic sensitivity and specificity
was defined.
And we certainly know that
mutations are present and widespread from
normal tissues as well as cancer.
So there is the natural progression there.
Yeah. Interpreting the mutations and which ones come from cancer, that
is something that of course we work on.
And some of those are
not technical artifacts, but if you wish, physiological
artifacts like CIP, for example. I don't need to get too much of
that because we're almost out of time.
But that we're trying to take also into account.
So yes, there are mutations in the blood that for some
reasons, but those are not the ones that we try to detect.
It's
a longer discussion, but we try to avoid those in certain
ways and technical things.
Okay. Let's call it good.
Tom, we gave up. Okay, one more.
Okay.
Sorry. Go ahead.
Daniel Grosso, previous at a number of MSAT companies.
So a lot of these conversations today and other presentations seem
to treat this as something that's like a one-time test.
Here is the study over a one-time testing or over a period of one year,
this is what happened. And to the point made by the gentleman
before, this is really a lifetime thing.
What we're proposing here is that once these tests become available,
paid,
people will start having them at age 50 until 75 or 80.
So it's really in the end about the cumulative performance over a
lifetime. Yeah, during one year, maybe the incidence of cancer in the population,
even the 50 plus, may be only 1% or so.
But over 20 years, 30 years, it's what?
One in two men, one in three women, and so on.
So I think the real question in the study is probably as time
goes by and the companies will be able to fund these, is what is
the sensitivity
for various cancer types and so on over 10 years, where
I get tested once every year?
And the same thing, what is the PPV given now the
cumulative prevalence over that period of time?
What is the PPV and what is the down staging? Would I have been caught earlier?
How many of those cancers would be caught based on
showing up at the doctor because of signs and symptoms versus
triggered by a positive
MSAT test? I think in the end, that will be the end
proof of the
clinical utility and the performance of these tests over a large number of
subjects in a cumulative year-by-year use as
indicated
scenario. I'm just curious to get people's perspectives.
This is a problem with all tests and trials.
They don't go on for the full
natural
screening lifetime.
It's hard for companies to fund 10-year trials and
No, they don't need to. They don't need to.
They don't need to, because we can learn enough to model and extrapolate out, and
that's what we've been doing for years.
From taking the trial results, learning the natural history,
learning how,
in the case of mortality trials, how earlier diagnosis translates
to extended life expectancy. Putting it into a model of a
longer time period, and then projecting it out, projecting out
cost-effectiveness. This is common practice, and I expect
that that will happen here, too. We can never do a trial that will cover the
screening
lifetime of an individual. So we take what we can learn and then
turn it into an intelligent extrapolation.
But I also think for all the measures you were talking about, you don't need a
control arm. And so we should be doing that
lifelong monitoring once you introduce screening, and that's
what I did in cervical screening for years, and you'd learn a
lot of things about what's happening over a life course.
Then, of course,
the benefits of screening may well change because treatments are going to
change. And so you can't expect one trial to answer
all the questions. And you need to think, what do you study
by randomized controlled trials, and what do you study with
eitherYes, specific randomized trials looking at
treatments or
doing modeling or doing single cohort studies.
Real quick. I think there are really practical ways of dealing with that challenge.
We do that all the time with the Cologuard test, for example, which was
evaluated on a one-time basis against
colonoscopy, is recommended every three years.
We now have 12 years of data, and we're able to look
at what happens
three years later and six years later.
And if, for example, we quit detecting any cancers after a while
because they were all cleaned up,
we would know that. That's not happening.
We continue to see
effects. It's not a perfect way to look at it, but on the other hand, we've got
millions of people worth of data, and it allows
us to continue to learn. So I think that's the way we're going to learn, is by
using and collecting data as we go.
Okay. I know we are over time, and I appreciate everybody who stayed
here. Thanks for the discussion. I think actually the
way that Tom maybe summarized that could be the final
words of the meeting, unless you guys, Ruth or Peter, want to add
anything.
And I apologize, I know we had a lot of discussion here for
45 minutes. We didn't get to the questions.
We have some questions online, but that's what you miss when you're not in
person. So I apologize.
That's what it is. So thank you very much.
Should I look at... It should be here.
That
was
fine.